pft power rankings you can check out the
full list of profitballtalk.com along
with my
justification for why the teams are
where they
are we created this because we need a
framework for doing a
team by team state of the state series
to get you ready for the 2020 season
we're going to start
with team number 32 that's washington
tomorrow
the chiefs at number one though and for
good reason the chiefs are the defending
champions
the chiefs are bringing back pretty much
everyone
and patrick mahomes and chris jones
making it clear
that they believe they can run it back
hashtag run it back in
2020. so chris let's ponder this
question super bowl champion
first of all it'll be a championship for
all of us if there is a super bowl this
year
chiefs or the field who you got well 20
20.
this is a team i mean we know
repeating's not easy as
we've only seen you know the patriots
are the only team that seem to be able
to go
two super bowls we haven't seen a whole
lot of teams repeat in general
as we know seahawks came close uh
this is a team that i seriously would
think about taking over the field
ultimately i'm not i'm still going to
take the field it's just too difficult
but
i do worry about it it'd be one of those
mike if i was going up to the
you know the the casino in vegas and i
had to lay down a bed i'd be like man
do i really want to bet against my homes
in this team because i do feel like
again when you win a super bowl this
early in your career
it's oh i mean he's going to be he i
just feel like this is just going to
catapult him into another level the
pressure's off there's no other
questions to be answered about patrick
mahomes career
and this is usually at flourishes
greatness right we saw brady won one
early in his career we saw joe montana
you know bradshaw won one pretty early
in his career
you know aikman got one pretty in the
first four years or so
three years so you know when you do that
the pressure's off you could just let it
fly
and i think they're the ultimate let it
fly team but i'm still going to pick the
field
uh what about you you know and and
you've raised an interesting point that
i'm going to research if i remember to
do it later today
the super bowl records of guys who
won their first super bowl game right
right how do they do
when they get back i think for the most
part they do pretty well i will say this
though
getting back is going to be the hard
part i'm taking the field without
question two reasons first of all
they were down 24 nothing to the texans
in the division around they were down 10
points twice
to the titans in the championship game
they were down 10 points with seven
minutes to go
they pulled the rabbit out of the hat
three different times i don't think you
can count on that happening again
and the pandemic makes everything
uncertain
the pandemic puts everything into the
blender yeah
if patrick mahomes gets coveted 19 and
misses a couple of games
that could be the difference between the
one seed and the two seed right right
uh or what if he gets it during the
postseason what if they
what if andy reid gets it and he's gone
for a month
right you don't have your head coach to
hold it all together yeah there's too
many variables with the pandemic and i
think the team that wins
the championship this year is the team
that
loses the fewest number of starters over
the course of the full season
to uh covert 19 positive i don't
disagree it's a very real
fact of the fact in this this year but
the good thing is they got their team
back right their coaches are back they
got no change so from that standpoint
like the 49ers there's not a lot of
moving parts like tampa bay who's got a
lot of different moving parts and things
so
should be interesting nonetheless
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the
latest news and highlights from nbc
sports